Ivan Moody is the front man for Five
Finger Death Punch he launched a
successful CBD brand called Moody's
medicinals and he has even bigger things
coming with a new brand called greenings
and it's a thrill to have him in studio
welcome to the show man man it's a
pleasure thank you for having me it's
nice to finally meet you dude as well I
know we've had cross paths a few times
but here we are going one on one yeah
CBD indeed let's go back to that how did
you get involved with that and how has
it helped you through the years
well getting involved with it would have
to stem back to when I was a child I
mean I grew up in Colorado so for me
holistic healing and and forms of like I
guess you'd say plant Health were always
something that I dabbled in and was
surrounded by
um so for me organic living has always
been something that I really held close
to my heart when I quit drinking about
five years ago
I have serious forms of anxiety and for
what I do going on stage yeah I started
using CBD in my Waters to kind of you
know kind of cool my Jets if you will
and so um I started thinking I was like
you know there's so many people out
there in recovery they're going through
kind of the same things I am that I
wanted to be a little more helpful and
so I went to my management team and we
started discussing ways that I could you
know kind of be more diverse and help
out so that's how that came about and
you just didn't stick your name on a
label you're involved with everything
and absolutely that is my own products
most definitely I think there are too
many companies out there that they put
their names on something and just throw
it to the wind almost like gummy bears
see if it sticks yeah I myself use it
and I so do a lot of my family members
and people I know so for me it was
something I'm very Hands-On about we
have a new Vegas Venture greenings at XL
in the Palms how's that different what's
this what do you have going on with
green this is THC based okay this is all
marijuana products and such
um and the idea behind that again is is
I grew up in an area where the that was
a Colorado legalized marijuana before he
was like they're way ahead of us
absolutely in a lot of ways
um so that that was just something again
it was second nature to me and it's
something that I use on a daily basis
and I just feel like it's time I think
the stigma of marijuana products and
stuff like that needs to be shadowed and
re-looked at so I wanted to be a part of
that and you're and you definitely are
and you're a Vegas guy now 18 years and
18 years man what do you like when
you're not like rocking the stage and
doing your thing what do you like to do
in Las Vegas everything the culture the
artwork here I mean go shopping on any
given night and find stuff in the world
you never see anywhere else I'm a
Knights fan first and foremost so
anytime we get a chance we're always the
games and uh yeah it's just Vegas it's
the culture if you haven't been here
well
disclaimer I grew up in Colorado so
first and foremost I'm a Bronco oh you
can get one of those I know a lot of
people like that you got your Broncos
but I'll tell you what team right
absolutely until they play your Broncos
indeed Raiders much better team this
year though I've heard I love it thank
you so much